en este vídeo vamos a tener una idea de
lo que son las fracciones vamos a
escribir aquí
fracciones
y una forma en la que podemos pensar va
a ser a través de estos dibujos vamos a
hacer diferentes opciones para que
ustedes vean cómo podemos imaginarnos
una fracción de diferentes formas que es
una fracción primero vamos a pensar en
este cuadrado
como un entero y le pondremos aquí
entero
este será nuestro entero una pieza
completa si nosotros llegáramos a
dividir este entero en cuatro partes
iguales haremos unos cortes digamos aquí
de manera horizontal
y así está dividido en dos partes y
ahora de manera vertical haremos otro
corte
lo que se ve bastante bien lo tenemos
ahora dividido en cuatro partes iguales
vamos a colocar que aquí hay cuatro
partes iguales 1 2 3 4
si nosotros dibujamos o colorea mos una
de estas partes con rojo que fracción de
nuestro entero estará en color rojo
ahora pues esto será muy sencillo de las
cuatro partes posibles que tenemos 1 2 3
4 sólo tenemos en rojo una de ellas y
eso nos representa un cuarto de nuestro
entero vamos a realizar algo similar con
este rectángulo que está en color rosa
llamaremos éste también entero esto es
un entero
sólo que esta vez vamos a pedirte que
identifiquemos uno sobre ocho o un
octavo qué es lo que haríamos para
lograr este un octavo
de entrada tomaríamos nuestro entero que
tenemos aquí y lo dividiría en ocho
partes iguales que sería más o menos así
tenemos aquí una mitad cada una
dividiremos en 2
tenemos cuatro y si cada una de éstas la
dividiéramos en dos tendríamos entonces
ocho partes iguales naturalmente no me
quedaron perfectas porque estoy haciendo
a mano pero pensemos que cada una de
estas ocho partes son exactamente ocho
partes iguales y estamos pidiendo en
color rojo una de ellas les mostraré en
tal vez ésta
y con esto lo que busco es que ustedes
vean que no siempre requiere ser la
primera parte puede ser
cualquiera de ellas mientras sea solo la
cantidad que estamos mostrando en este
número de arriba o numerador entonces
tenemos una de las 8 partes iguales
dibujadas con color rojo
esto es una fracción una parte de este
gran total podemos verlo de dos maneras
podemos decir que tengo cuatro partes
iguales de las cuales he tomado una
o que esta representación dibujada me
representa esta fracción que tengo aquí
abajo vamos a hacer un par de ejercicios
más bueno vamos a hacer tres les
mostraré unas imágenes que ya hicimos
previamente y con las que ustedes podrán
pausar el vídeo y hacerlo solos vamos a
dejarlo aquí para que tengan espacio los
invito a que hagan en una hoja de papel
o que aquí mismo ustedes vayan pensando
cuál será la fracción que representa en
este cuadrado rosa la porción roja en
este círculo o pay azul la porción roja
y en este triángulo amarillo la porción
roja
ok veamos cada uno de ellos asumiendo
que pasaron el vídeo vamos a trabajar
con cada uno de ellos en este caso este
cuadrado lo tenemos dividido en una dos
tres partes iguales vamos a colocar que
está dividido en tres partes iguales
mismo caso con el círculo opa y tenemos
una dos tres cuatro o cinco partes
iguales colocaremos que está dividido en
cinco partes iguales tenemos cinco
posibilidades y en este caso el
triángulo está dividido en
1 2 3 4 partes
vamos bien ahora vamos a trabajar con lo
que está dibujado en rojo de estas tres
partes iguales tenemos una de ellas
dibujada en rojo le estoy remarcando
para que ustedes la vean
por lo que de 1 2 3 partes iguales
tenemos una de ellas y esto nos
representa un tercio de nuestro cuadrado
vamos con el círculo o pay tenemos 1 2 3
4 5 partes iguales y una de ellas
está también dibujado en rojo vamos a
colocar que tenemos una de estas cinco
partes o un quinto como fracción
ahora este es un ejercicio interesante
tenemos un triángulo y dijimos que está
dividido en cuatro partes
sin embargo puse mucho cuidado en no
decirles que son partes iguales porque
ustedes pueden ver cómo son distintas lo
ven este pedazo que tenemos aquí es
distinto que éste
o que esté o que esté por lo tanto no
podemos hablar de una fracción recuerda
que una fracción implica que está
dividido nuestro entero en partes
iguales por lo tanto aquí no podemos
hablar de una fracción porque no está
dividido en partes iguales